savez vous que ça le 16 pour cent des
employés se disent impliqués dans leur
travail
c'est le résultat d'un sondage qui est
paru l'a dépassé en allemagne la
question était simple et vous impliquez
pas impliqué ou activement par impliqué
dans votre travail et à cette question
seuls 16% des gens répondent qu'ils sont
impliqués dans le travail
c'est un peu comme si seuls les deux
premiers rangs et s'ils écoutaient et
pourtant on passe plus de temps au
travail que avec nos amis quand famille
même qu'à dormir on peut se demander
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose de
fondamentalement faux de notre façon de
vivre la vie en entreprise
moi j'ai la chance de faire partie c'est
16% et c'est notamment parce que chez
lipp
on n'a pas de chef 0 aucun on est ce
quand on est une entreprise self manager
autogéré non on est pas on n'est pas
communiste
on gagne pas tous le même salaire ont
fait pas tous la même chose on n'a juste
pas de chef
et en fait on n'est pas non plus 10 dans
une cave
on est quand même 140 sur cinq sites
pendant six romande mais en suisse est
en fait la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler de ce management
c'était au début d'année passée à notre
conférence annuelle quand je rigole un
des fondateurs d'entreprise a fait un
toc qui s'appelait let's get rid of
management
débarrassons-nous du management
franchement je me base c'était un taux
parmi d'autres donc c'est une conférence
qu on a une référence interne
au début il y avait que quelques
personnes qui écoutait après il n'avait
de plus en plus finalement il ya presque
toute l'entreprise qui était là et je me
rappelle très bien je me suis dit 'mais
c'est vrai ce qu'il dit là où qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'il entend exactement
par là et on est il a continué sans
toque il a expliqué un petit peu ce que
c'était que le self management
mais imaginez vous vous êtes là dans une
salle et il ya votre le buzz de la boîte
qui dit mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
enlever toute toute cette structure
hiérarchique quand on a évidemment ça
fait un peu bizarre
la structure qu'on avait à ce moment là
chez lipp c'était ça donc on avait le
management
six personnes sur 100 donc c'était déjà
une structure relativement plate même
très plate le management s'occupait
surtout de choses très nouvelles comme
les salaires les entretiens de annuel la
vision de l'entreprise et tout le reste
de l'entreprise était organisée en team
cross fonctionnel on dit tim cross
fonctionnel parce qu'en fait elle
intègre tous les corps de métiers
nécessaires pour faire un projet donc on
a autant un vendeur des développeurs un
mixeur un designer tous ces gens ça
forme une petite équipe qui devient
autonome et indépendante
on était vraiment indépendant parce
qu'on pouvait prendre une décision qu'on
voulait on reste une entreprise au
service donc évidemment on est au
service du client
mais en fait on pouvait au delà de ça du
moment qu'on avait des pas des comptes
équilibrés mais disons que on avait des
résultats équilibrés
on pouvait vraiment prendre les
décisions qu'on voulait on était aussi
c'étaient des petites équipes donc une
dizaine de personnes on se connaissait
bien
on s'entraide et beaucoup et je pense
que ces équipes cros fonctionnel ça a
été notre premier pas vers le management
l'idée du toc de frigo c'est qu'on
pouvait être allé encore plus loin dans
cette direction pourquoi est-ce qu'on
appliquerait pas à toute l'entreprise
ce qu'on avait fait avec avec les teams
en fait c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
ce management ces six personnes ça
commençait à devenir un petit peu un
goulot d'étranglement
on avait
évidemment par exemple pour des pour des
choses comme les entretiens annuels ou
les salaires c'est clair que si personne
sur 50 va ça va bien six personnes sur
cent ça commence à devenir un petit peu
limite et l'entreprise continue à
grandir
donc ça devenait de plus en plus
difficile on avait aussi d'autres rôles
comme enfin ça fait quelques rôles à
l'époque mais d'autres postes comme
marketing ou communication ou
administrations qui faisaient pas partie
ni des teams ni du management et qui
commençait à sentir un peu perdus dans
cette structure d'entreprise
donc on sentait bien qu'on ait besoin de
se structurer
mais en même temps on voulait pas perdre
ce qui avait fait notre force du sel
jusqu'à là c'est à dire la possibilité
l'autonomie la possibilité de faire des
propositions à tous les niveaux tout le
temps après le thon qui de frais goût
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser au sein du
management et notamment à la lecture de
la bible du self management le livre de
frédéric laloux inventing organizations
puis j'ai remarqué à quel point on
partage et en fait des valeurs avec ces
entreprises la transparence le
l'autorité partager il ya aussi cette
chose assez assez important c'est l'euro
metz c'est le fait de pouvoir être
soi-même en entreprise autant en
entreprise qu en dehors d'entreprise et
pas devoir mettre un masque pour venir
au travail
bon tout ça c'est très joli sur le
papier mais moi je suis comme vous quand
j'ai entendu parler de ça je me suis dit
ok c'est bien mais on a une entreprise
qui marche bien on a des clients qui
sont contents on a des employés qui sont
contents est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
fou de vouloir tout changer une partie
la réponse est probablement oui mais en
même temps on sait que c'est quand les
choses vont bien qu'il faut les faire
évoluer
et après ce taux qui a eu beaucoup de
débats il ya eu beaucoup de peur aussi
évidemment finalement on s'est décidé à
faire un test grandeur nature de la
croatie à la craie si c'est une des
implémentations très con
creat du seul management asset
management le self management c'est
plutôt d un concept des préceptes et à
la création c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très concret aujourd'hui la structure
d'entreprise ça donne plutôt cinq donc
le credo de al aqra cissé organizers
work note de people organiser le travail
et pas les relations entre les gens on
va donc partager le travail à faire et
on va créer des rôles pour faire ce
travail
chaque rôle sera défini par sa raison
d'être
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a créé ce rôle
pourquoi est ce qu'il existe et c'est
redevabilité accountability d'anglais
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ce rôle
à ce qui est fondamental à on voit qu'il
ya aussi dans quels rôles épiler sert
qu'une fois que plusieurs cercles ont
beaucoup de communication entre beaucoup
de choses à faire entre l on en forme en
fait un cercle
ce qui est complètement différent entre
un rôle ici et un poste en
normal dans une structure hiérarchique
c'est que le rôle peut faire ce qu'il
veut
pour atteindre sa raison d'être donc il
est vraiment libre de faire ce qu'il
veut il a pâti chef n'y a pas une ligne
de commande qui lui dit quoi faire et
lui même ne demande rien d'autre
cette idée de deux parloirs de chefs ça
paraît un peu dingue quand enfin quand
on est habitué au système hiérarchique
mais en même temps on fait dans la vie
réelle en dehors de l'entreprise on n'a
jamais de chef et pourtant on arrive
très bien s'en sortir même dans les
situations relativement complexe
pourquoi est-ce que des cons et en
entreprise on devrait avoir un chef
ce qui est intéressant avec la croatie
c'est que on sépare le rôle de la
personne
donc moi par exemple en ce moment j'ai
une dizaine de rôles dans l'entreprise
j'ai autant des rôles qui sont très
projets orientés projets par exemple je
suis scrum master dans une des équipes
que des rôles qui sont plus orientés
on pourrait dire rh genre à la clé six
rapports pour aider à l'implémentation
de la crécy ou people développement pour
le développement des collaborateurs dans
une structure classique je serais obligé
choisir entre être d'un côté ou de
l'autre je pourrais pas être des deux
côtés à la fin donc par exemple rh où on
a un truc plus business projet là j'ai
vraiment la possibilité d'utiliser tout
mon potentiel tout mais tout ce que je
peux donner à l'entreprise à tous les
niveaux le fait qu'on sépare aussi le
rôle de l'entreprise sa coupe beaucoup
des problèmes humains qu'on a qu'on
trouve souvent dans les système
hiérarchique légaux la frustration tout
les systèmes politiques qui convoie dans
le système hiérarchique
là on a vu qu il n'y a plus cette
possibilité de déchoir à grimper on va
devoir se réinventer rey a mis à
imaginer ce qu'on veut vraiment faire en
fait dans l'entreprise on peut plus
juste dire à raymond proches ma
prochaine étape ce sera de d'avoir ce
seul gallon la cette offre se présen ce
prochain échelon on veut plus prendre la
place du chef parce qu'il ya pas de chef
chaque rôle devient aussi un capteur
donc un capteur de tension un capteur de
deux portes unités par exemple si je
suis admettant que je sois vendeurs dans
cette dans ce cercle a qui représente ma
ma team ce qu'on appelait avant une team
et que je vois qu'on fait des projets
super mais en fait que les gens ne nous
connaissent pas on n'en parle pas assez
la première au prochain meeting de
gouvernance et un meeting qu'on a toutes
les trois semaines sur lesquels on
essaye de réfléchir à la structure de
notre cercle
je vais pouvoir proposer par exemple de
faire un nouveau rôle qui va s'appeler
communication ce rôle je vais lui donner
une raison d'être de
faire le buzz autour de nos projets et
le rôle sera créé donc on voit qu'on est
dans une structure qui est complètement
en dynamique
on peut plus l'affiché à l'entrée de
l'entreprise parce que ça change tout le
temps et ça ce que je viens de vous
décrire ça se passe dans tous les
cercles a évidemment ses schémas très
simplifiées il ya beaucoup plus de
cercle dans dans la réalité et ce
meeting de gouvernance qui permet de
réfléchir se passe dans tous les cercles
on a aussi vu que j'ai pas fait une
proposition générique j'ai pas essayé de
trouver une solution pour toute
l'entreprise
j'ai vraiment fait j'ai ressenti une
tension et j'ai essayé d'en faire
quelque chose j'ai fait une proposition
et voilà maintenant on a ce rôle de
communication qui a été créé ça me mène
un autre point important on dans al aqra
si on cherche pas jamais le consensus
donc on est en fait une ressens quelque
chose on va faire une proposition dans
le cadre de meetings gouvernance de mon
sac et là les autres rôles vont pouvoir
me poser des questions et ensuite vont
pouvoir donner leur avis l'un après
l'autre genre ainsi que la possibilité
de choisir ce que je veux faire avec
leur avis si je veux changer ma
proposition ou pas mais eux et je
continue avec la proposition j'ai
vraiment envie d'avoir ce rôle de
communication et maintenant les gens
vont pouvoir faire des objections il
mais ils vont devoir prouver qu'en fait
cette proposition peut nuire à
l'entreprise ou que ça peut nous ramener
en arrière romandie donc ce qui est
vraiment différent par rapport à un
système habituel c'est qu'on va pas
testé la proposition va pas se demander
si c'est une bonne idée de faire ça ou
pas mais on va tester l'objection est
donc on coupe complètement cette espèce
de fausse dynamique on a en général où
les gens commencent à se dire oui mais
est-ce que tu es sûr que c'est une bonne
idée non là je ressens quelque chose je
fais une proposition c'est une bonne
idée
par contre est ce que toi tu es sûr que
ton objections et le valable et que ça
fait vraiment du temps pour l'entreprise
ou pas
la dynamique donc est complètement
inversé et on arrive vers quelque chose
de nouveau de très dynamique
je vous propose un petit un petit test
alors on a créé ce rôle de communication
donc si c'est qu'ils sont chefs est ce
que c'est moi qui suis le plus vieux de
du cercle de ce cercle là où est ce que
c'est le responsable marketing pour tout
ce qui est marketing de l'entreprise
1-2-3 ya pas de chef
bravo merci qui est soufflée
effectivement il n'y a pas de chef
donc je j'ai un rôle et je vais faire ce
que je veux pour le pour y arriver
d'ailleurs dans l'ue que dans ce cadre
là je décide en tant que communication à
dire c'est monsieur qui a pris le rôle
il décide de dépenser 500 francs en
douane parce que pour faire le buzz
autour nos projets il faut acheter des
adwords est ce que il peut le faire ou
pas dorel acratie un truc un peu
spéciale avec l'argent parce
qu'évidemment c'est américains les gens
ils ont toujours un petit peu peur de
l'argent mais chez nous on a fait une
règle en appelle une politique qui dit
que chaque rôle peut dépenser ce qu'il
veut dans le cadre de son de son rôle
justement de son de sa raison d'être
bravo tu as passé franchement pour moi
le changement la croatie a était
vraiment bénéfique et mai mais je suis
toujours un peu étonnée qu'on ait osé
faire ce pain j'ai été demandé aux
ex-membres du management ce qui les
avait convaincus de d'aller plus loin on
voit déjà la réponse de gerhardt en et
les fondateurs d'entreprises aussi
guerre ou pour les intimes
je vous laisse une mine sur la lire mais
attention j'ai choisi ce midi
donc il ya deux choses que j'aime bien
dans cette réponse la première c'est
qu'on le sache management c'est pas les
mauves herman ça dans les moeurs même ya
cette idée que on a de l'autorité et
qu'on la distribution va donner de
l'autorité on est dans une relation très
parents enfants
on essaie on a envie que nos enfants
face au mieux mais c'est quand même nous
qui avons l'autorité choisir dans le
style management on reçoit pâlotte
l'autorité on l'a et puis à l'autre
partie c'est vrai que pour plusieurs
managers ça a été un fait un soulagement
de pouvoir faire ce qu'ils aiment et
faire vraiment ce pourquoi il avait créé
l'entreprise plutôt que de devoir faire
du management ce qu'ils étaient ce qu'il
était amené à faire avec le temps on
voit maintenant la réponse de l'oukase
un autre ex membre du management
encore une minute
ça lui aussi aime le club parce que
c'est vrai donc on est on est passé
d'abord au team cross fonctionnel puis à
la croatie et on voit que ça les gens
sont plus impliqués sont plus motivés et
donc ça améliore nos résultats et ils
sont en fait une fine et plus content
aussi
évidemment vu quand on enlève toutes les
barrières on ça va booster l'innovation
et ça permet aussi d'autres initiatives
comme moi par exemple en ce moment je
participe à la à la refonte de notre
politique salariale avec d'autres
personnes dans l'entreprise
c'est quelque chose que je n'aurais pas
forcément pu faire avant
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de travailler
avec des rôles bien définis dans un but
commun je communique beaucoup plus avec
les différents bureaux différents rôles
qu'avant en toute transparence partout
tout le temps et j'ai la chance de
pouvoir être moi-même du lever au
coucher en passant par ma vie en
entreprise
en général quand tu parles de la cra si
on me dit oui ça a l'air très bien ton
très que franchement cool mais en fait
le système hiérarchique ça marche très
bien aussi
et c'est vrai que les système
hiérarchique ça marche bien on il ya
plein de choses fantastiques qui ont été
créés grâce au système hiérarchique mais
on fait quoi avec ses 84 % de gens qui
s'ennuient
je me rends bien compte que on va pas
tous passer demain aux seiches
management ou à la craie six jeunes ou
le souhaite mais mais j'ai l'impression
que si on pouvait utiliser un peu plus
souvent
certains de ces préceptes et ses
concepts on serait juste tous un peu
plus heureux merci